let me tell you a few things that will
happen
you heard we have an extra service this
coming sabbath is five o'clock
let me tell you the reason for that
we will have a healing service
god does not like sickness among his
people
and god desires to relieve us of our
suffering
so this coming sabbath afternoon we will
have a healing service based on james
chapter 5 verses 14 through 16. now
there's some verses i want you to write
down and i will tell you how to prepare
for the healing service let me give you
the preparation steps now
if you're sick
and you want to be part of the healing
service here's what we're asking you to
do
we believe that sickness
and sin
go together
which means healing and forgiveness have
to go together somebody say amen
all
right step number one
if you have done someone something wrong
find that person
between now and sabbath afternoon
and apologize
did i say something abusive
no okay
if you have done something wrong to
someone and you know it you have sinned
against someone find that person
and say you're sorry
two
if someone has hurt you
and you are as innocent as a goose
but someone has hurt you
because
god for christ's sake hath forgiven you
you find that person and say
you did this and this to me it caused me
great harm it caused me financial loss a
damn whatever it was let the person know
what he or she did and then say but
because i have been touched by the
spirit of god i have come to say what
i forgive you
what does the lord's prayer say forgive
us our debts as
if we do not forgive people god
will not forgive us
and step number three
if there is something in your life you
know to be sin
right now
confess it
and put it away
then you come
we'll pray
anoint you with oil
now let me give you the biblical
connections between healing
and
spiritual healing as well
exodus chapter 15 verse 26 please write
this down then we'll get into our
message the science of the resurrection
exodus 15 verse 26 the bible says
and this is god speaking to the
israelites and said if thou wilt
diligently hearken to the voice of the
lord thy god
and will do that which is right in his
sight
and will keep his commandments
and give ear to all his statutes i will
put none of these diseases upon you
that i have brought upon the egyptians i
am the lord that does what
healthy
next verse
uh exodus 23 verse 25 write that one
down
exodus 23 verse 25
and ye shall serve the lord your god
notice what comes first he shall serve
the lord your god and he shall bless
your bread and your water and i will
take sickness away from the midst of you
but there is service connected first
line notice exodus 15 26 if thou will
diligently hearken to the voice of the
lord thy god and will do that which is
right in his sight
i will give ear to his commandments and
keep all his statutes
that's obedience
i will put none of these diseases on you
text number three psalm 103 verse 3
all we can read from verse 1 bless the
lord o my soul and all that is within me
bless his holy name bless the lord oh my
soul and forget not all his benefits
verse 38 who forgiveth how many
iniquities
all thy iniquities who healeth how many
diseases all thy diseases in these three
verses we have seen obedience to god's
will
and the removal of sickness
passage number four james chapter five
reading from verse fourteen
please write that down
james five reading from verse fourteen
is twenty after seven i want to jump
into the message but this is important
is any sick among you let him call for
the elders of the church
and let them pray over him anointing him
with oil in the name of the lord and the
prayer of faith shall save the sick and
the lord shall raise him up
and if he hath committed sins here we
have sins again
they shall be forgiven him
confess your faults one to another and
pray for one another that ye may be
healed
go and tell people you've done wrong
apologize forgive those who've hurt you
confess your faults one to another and
pray for one another that ye may be
healed the effectual fervent prayer of a
righteous man availeth much i was
telling some friends today i believe
many people in church are sick for one
reason only
they do not
take advantage of james 5 14 to
and so they remain sick needlessly
and so this coming sabbath afternoon at
five we shall have the healing service
i'll give you another verse mark chapter
six
reading verse 13
mark 6 13 the bible says and they cast
out many devils and anointed with oil
many that were sick and
healed them
mark 16 verses 17 and 18
in 15 we're told go into all the world
and preach the gospel to every creature
and then in verses 17 and 18 jesus gives
some signs that will follow they shall
speak in tongues they shall take up
dangerous things not be heard and they
shall lay hands on the sick and they
will recover the preaching of the gospel
must be accompanied by the evidences of
god's miraculous power
of course the greatest evidence of god's
power is a changed life don't ever
forget that
the greatest evidence of god's existence
is his word
the greatest proof that jesus was god is
not that he raised lazarus but that he
fulfilled every old testament prophecy
you see that's the word
but christ miracles were the reason why
some people believed
he said at one point if you don't
believe what i say
then believe what i do
in john 15 verse 22 he said if i have
not come and spoken unto them they had
not had sin in verse 24 he says if i had
not done among them the works which none
other man did meaning by my words that's
the witness of who i am by my works the
word is a message of the gospel the
works the miracles that he performed as
a support for the message
i'm not here to say god will heal every
single person i don't know what god will
do i'm not in his mind but i do know
this i have seen god heal
people
and there's no reason why
he will not do it here if you were sick
you know the preparations the three
things i said one more thing 23 after
seven
if you know someone who is sick
you're fine but you know someone who's
sick you can represent that person in
the service you have to go through the
same preparation and get that person's
permission and the person does the same
thing you have a grandfather in
jacksonville wyoming or some place
and you call him you say grandad we're
having a healing service and the
preacher said to do thus thus thus are
you willing granddad says yes
will you give me permission to represent
you yes you and he become one
in the preparation he does it you do it
then you represent him i have seen god
heal people who were not present they
were hundreds of miles away but they
were represented remember the man who
was lowered through the roof
he was out of it
the bible says when jesus saw whose
faith
faith of the friends
what did he do
he healed a man
we can stand in the gap for people
let me tell you quickly last year i was
in a kenya doing a crusade and i had a
healing service and i told the people
exactly what i just said this lady stood
for a little baby she had been in the
hospital about three months with
leukemia and was there for three months
they told me this lady stood for her it
was her aunt
we had the healing service the next day
the doctors did their usual examination
not knowing that the aunt had stood in
the healing service and they found no
sign of leukemia or whatsoever the baby
was discharged the next day and they
sent me an email
why isn't the roof coming off with amen
over there they do shout
they do here i guess we don't because
the hospital is right here but god can
do miracles for us he can and he wants
to
let's pray
father we come to you in the name of
jesus
we have about 30 minutes left father i
have so much to say
if i need five extra minutes father
soften the hearts of your people that
they may give that to me now grant me
the words to say and give them a heart
that loves truth i offer this prayer in
jesus name and for his sake amen the
science of the resurrection genesis
chapter 2 reading from verse 16
genesis chapter 2 reading from verse 16.
someone sent a question uh why do you
read from the king james i just like it
i love the language that's all
but read whatever version you have so i
just thought i'd say that i didn't have
a vision that i should use this in
another i just love the language verse
16 genesis 2 and the lord god commanded
the man saying of every tree of the
garden thou may freely eat but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
thou shalt not eat of it for in the day
thou eat is thereof finish it with me
thou
shalt
surely die now
in chapter 3 verse 9
the bible says
and the lord god called unto adam and
said unto him where are thou
and he said i heard thy voice in the
garden and i was afraid because i was
naked and i hid myself in verse 11 and
he said who told me that thou was naked
hath thou eaten of the tree whereof i
commanded thee that thou should not eat
now what is god saying god is comparing
what adam did
with what he said
are you following me
there are people who believe all you
need is grace and then do what you like
god is examining obedience
god said adam as far as i can remember
and i don't forget
i told you don't eat of this tree and
the word i use was command the very
first use of the word command is in
genesis 2 16. now adam
how do you know you are naked did you do
what i told you not to do in other words
did you
disobey
go contrary to my will
when god was handing out the judgments
or the punishments in verse 17
he said adam and unto adam he said
because thou has hearken unto the voice
of thy wife and has eaten of the tree of
which i commanded this saying thou shalt
not eat of it curse is the ground for i
say god said because you disobeyed
because you went contrary to what i said
we have to understand that at the very
heart of sin
is a deliberate going contrary to the
will of god
i'll say something more serious
sin
originated with satan
let's go to isaiah 14.
isaiah 14.
let's read verse
13. isaiah 14 13 we continue with
the science of the resurrection we have
to under establish first that the
terrible reality that sin is
for thou has said in thy heart i will
ascend into heaven i will exalt my
throne above the stars of god i will sit
also upon the mount of the congregation
in the size of the north i will ascend
above the heights of the clouds i will
be like the most high now this was
lucifer's ambition he wanted to replace
god this is sin
john 8 44 jesus speaking ear of your
father the devil and the lusts of your
father you will do he was a murderer
from the beginning now this beginning
goes way past adam
it goes right back to his attack on
jesus christ and his government sin is a
direct attack on the government of god
sin is 11 against heaven
are you listening to me
it is a direct attack one of the
problems we have we have a benign
approach to sin we view sin as it is
just poor judgment
sin is well i wouldn't do that i'm sorry
you did it and that's our attitude to
sin just poor judgment bad choice sin is
a direct attack against the government
of god if a sinner were to be allowed to
live as long as is possible and for sin
to work out itself it would culminate on
that person trying to kill god
at its highest
expression
sin
is an attempt
on the life of god
calvary shows us that
sin
is an attempt to kill god
now we do that in many little ways we
try to kill
and silence and remove him from our
lives
sin is not just bad judgment sin is
homicidal towards god it is murderous
and that's what adam did
he sinned
against god
by sinning against god you see to go
against one thing you have to go for
something else because the bible is
clear there are always two choices he
that is not for me finish it for me is
against me he that is not scattering
with me is he is not gathering with me
is scattering against me two choices
from genesis to revelation to sin
against god you've got to cooperate with
another power
adam
lead with the devil against god
that sin
and so
the penalty for that
is death
we talked about that death earlier today
it is the second death
what else is sin
sin
the bible says is transgression
of god's law
first john chapter 3
verse 4
it is transgression of god's law
now god's law has always been in place
because his law is a reflection of
himself
god's law is the very foundation of the
government of god which is the ruling
power in the universe
let me say that again god's law is the
foundation of his government which is
the ruling power in the universe but it
has been challenged if you read exodus
chapter 25
verse 16 when god gave moses
instructions for the construction of the
ark
the central piece of furniture in the
tabernacle i say the central as a matter
of fact all that happened all the
services were actually focused on the
ark and what the ark represented and
what it contained because it contained
that which was violated that's god's law
so verse 16 exodus 25 the bible said and
thou shalt put into the ark the
testament which i shall give thee
the testimony being the ten commandments
you ask me how do i know that exodus 31
verse 18
the bible says and he gave unto moses
when he had made an end of communion
with him upon mount sinai two tables of
testimony tables of stone written with
the finger of god the ten commandments
are a testimony what is a testimony a
testimony is a witness a testimony of a
statement supporting something the ten
commandments are testimonies of who god
is what he stands for his character they
testify of the character of god they are
a witness of the goodness of god the
righteousness of god the holiness of god
the ten commandments are as sacred as
god himself and they are the foundation
of his throne sin
was an attack against that foundation it
was an attack against god himself i am
trying to paint sin in as ugly a picture
as i possibly can
when you think about a little sin or i
think about a little sin
what is a little attempt to kill me
does that mean you lose a small gun
a small knife a symbol full of poison
what is a small attempt to kill someone
sin is an attempt on god's life
attempting his government this is what
satan did this is what adam did in
cooperation with the power that
originally attacked god the devil is in
terrible thing
violation
of god's law
attack against god's government
and the penalty for that
is death
not just
the death which we die every day
but the second death from which there is
no return now we're talking about the
science of the resurrection
now not simply death
not the death of anyone because an angel
could not come and die
i am sure the angels wanted to come and
die in the place of jesus christ because
they love him
i am sure gabriel the highest angel
wanted to come and die but sin is so
grievous the payment for sin has to be
made by someone equal to the law that
sin went against
you can tell how horrible sin is
by who hung on that cross
you see
this was god
equal with the father this was the god
who created the heavens and the earth
the very creator had to pay the penalty
for sin that tells us how horrible sin
is and how tremendous the price that has
to be paid the death
of one member of the godhead jesus
christ in human form in a form that made
him
able to die and of course able to be
tempted so jesus came
he lived
and he died
there are some people who say the death
of christ was enough
the atonement finished on the cross he
just had to die that's it
have you ever considered if all jesus
had to do was die there was no need for
him to get up
are you listening to me
if all that was necessary was for jesus
to die there was no need for him to come
from the grave
but he came from the grave
you see the death of jesus christ is the
penalty
for sin
he paid it
when he died
but now he has to give us power
to live
free from the power of sin
that
power
is his resurrected life
are you following me it is his
resurrected life
it is a mystery that cannot be fully
explained how can a dead man raise
himself but that's what jesus did when
the bible says the father raised him it
simply means the father authorized him
to get up when he did but jesus's
resurrected life provides the power to
live victoriously after we have accepted
the payment for our sins his death was
the payment the bible is clear the wages
of sin is death
so he died
now having paid the price how shall we
live
by my life
if we are justified by his death we
shall be saved by his life paul tells us
and so jesus came up from the grave we
have talked about that now paul is at
pains to make it clear that the
resurrection actually happened
and that's why i call this subject the
science of the resurrection 23 minutes
left let's go to first corinthians 15.
we shall read from verse 3.
first corinthians 15 verse 3
and this is paul speaking to a church
that had a problem with the doctrine of
the resurrection they thought there was
no resurrection and there's no
resurrection there's no gospel
no gospel no salvation we're all lost
and christ is not even risen from the
dead
for i delivered unto you first of all
that which i also receive says paul
how that christ died for our sins
according to the scriptures
and that he was buried and that he rose
again the third day according to the
scriptures verse five and that he was
seen of cephas and then of the twelve
and after that he was seen of about 500
brethren at once the greater part of
whom remained to this present but some
of them are fallen asleep after that he
was seen of james then of all the
apostles and finally he was seen of me
as if one born out of time last of all
he was seen of me paul is assembling
his witnesses to prove that jesus christ
came up from that grave
now the bible tells us
in first timothy chapter 5 verse 19 you
don't need to turn there
against an elder
receive not an accusation except before
two or three witnesses
now follow me closely i want to
linger on witnesses
against an elder anyone who is an elder
in the church can i see your hands any
elders in the churches god bless you you
cannot bring an accusation against that
man
or that man unless you have two or three
people with you the bible forbids you
i think it's deuteronomy 1915 the bible
says no man
can be punished or put to death on the
testimony of one witness
deuteronomy 76 in the mouth or two or
three witnesses shall he that is worthy
of death be put to death but in the
mouth of one witness here shall he not
be put to death a man in the days when
god had this theocracy he could not be
put to death based on the testimony of
one witness there had to be at least two
or three
in john chapter 5
jesus from verse 30 that right down to
verse 47 jesus gives all those who
witness to the fact that he was indeed
the son of god
he talked about john the baptist
then he talks about the miracles that he
did then he goes down that his father
was a witness then in verse 39 the
scriptures are witnessed you search the
scriptures friends then you think you
have eternal life and there there which
testify of me then verse 45 to 47 moses
and in john 8 14 he himself is a witness
he knows that in the jewish system there
must be witnesses for something to be
established as a fact
acts 5 32
peter says and we are witnesses of these
things and so also is the holy ghost
talking about the events of the
crucifixion of christ peter said we are
witnesses and the holy ghost is the
witness god requires the testimony of
witnesses
now the righteousness of god is revealed
apart from the law being witnessed by
the law and the prophets the law and the
prophet's witness to the righteousness
apart from works
paul is calling witnesses
and in verse 5
first corinthians 15
and he was seen of cephas
then of the twelve that's one witness so
he's saying if you don't believe me go
talk to peter
after that he was seen of about 500
brethren at once they all saw jesus
christ at the same time so each person
can check the other person's story if
jesus had appeared to them individually
each person could have given an
individual account you know how
eyewitnesses report accidents
each person says something different
so eyewitness accounts are very
unreliable in the court of law i'm told
i'm no lawyer
they're not absolutely reliable because
people tend to see different things
under stress
paul probably knows that paul is saying
well 500 people can't be wrong
he's calling 500 a few of them died but
the greater part remain to this presence
says paul then in the next verse he says
after that he was seen of james as the
blood of jesus
then of all the apostles now in verse 5
peter sees him on the 12th in verse 7
james and all the apostles
hundreds of people
of all the events in the life of christ
the resurrection
is the most verifiable
by that i mean
biblically
it is easiest to establish and the
principles upon which it is established
are scientific when you write your term
paper in your research paper do you use
witnesses
what do you call them
footnotes
or endnotes
and you say
that linus pauling said
and you put that in your research and
vitamin c
and you say that ben carson said you put
out in your research in pediatric
neurosurgery and this person said and
that person said and you call a cloud of
witnesses and then you present your
paper and you get an a because a is for
adventists can you say amen
you use your footnotes witnesses
well paul does the same thing he uses
footnotes with feet people
500 maybe 600 why because paul is
desperate to establish that the
resurrection actually happened now why
is the resurrection necessary i told you
it provides the power for us to live it
provides the power to develop that
character that goes from earth to heaven
unchanged
when jesus comes
he changes
our body
let's go to philippians chapter 3.
you know sometimes if you see me talking
too quickly when i get excited all you
have to do is
i'll see you the camera won't catch you
and i will know you mean especially if
english is not your first language i
tend to get excited so all you have to
do is preacher well i don't like that no
just
and i will slow down if i can afford to
base on the swift passage of time did i
say philippians
what chapter did i say
what verse
i didn't
okay dr shahid the verse is 20.
philippians 3 verse 20
paul says
for our conversation
is in heaven meaning our citizenship
you see in verse 17 paul had told the
brethren
use me as an example follow me on my my
apostles you see in verse 20 says why
for our conversation is in heaven
from whence also we look for the savior
the lord jesus who shall do what change
our vile bodies which is this one
that it might be fashioned according to
what
his glorious body according to the
working whereby he's able to subdue even
all things unto himself paul is saying
when jesus came we are looking for him
to come because when he comes he will
change this vile body
we will undergo an immediate bodily
change and the power that god uses to
change the body paul says is the same
power he uses to hold the entire
universe together whereby he's able even
to subdue all things unto himself
colossians 1 17 and him all things
consist
and that power is the power of life
a flower at the side of the road
unfurling its colors and releasing its
aroma it does not by the controlling
power that originates from the creator
himself
this is the very power that god uses to
transform us in the twinkling of an eye
it is the same power he uses
to sustain us as we take this spiritual
walk it is the very resurrection power
of jesus christ the power over death the
power over hell the power of the grave
the power over the devil the power of
all those things that scare us and
terrify us even as we call ourselves
christians the power to live free
from the terror of the grave and the
terror of the enemy and the terror of
hell is the resurrected life of jesus
christ
and that life comes to you
and to me
when we by faith receive jesus christ
my beloved brothers
i am trying to get across to you as
clearly as i can
there is power
available from christ to live
now as if we're already in heaven
let me repeat that
name some people who are in heaven
quickly
enoch nice man someone else
moses someone else
elijah someone else
jesus is a man that's right somebody say
amen jesus is a human being now he's
also god but he's still human being paul
says there's one media between god and
man the man christ jesus
colossians two verse nine
in him dwelleth the fullness of the
godhead how
boldly
christ is now glorified human flesh but
human
so yes jesus is there who else is there
those resurrected when christ came from
the grave the 420 elders and others who
were there they are in heaven now how do
you think they live by what law and by
what principle
heaven's laws
give me three words for heaven's laws
the
yes
that's all the law heaven has
are you with me
that's all the law
heaven has
that was the law lucifer violated so the
bible says in first john 3 verse 8
he that committed sinners of the devil
for the devil sinneth from the beginning
that was the law the angels broke second
peter chapter 2 verse 4
for if god spared not the angels that
sin but cast them down to hell
this has been god's standard of living
from eons from everlasting unto
everlasting god never changes his
standards
and what god does his standard is so
high
you see if the standard by which jesus
lives now is the standard by which i am
supposed to live i need help
because i am not born with a mind for
that kind of living
may i politely say you need help
can i have an amen
you look as though you do and so do i
what does that help the very life of
christ
and christ demonstrated the power of his
life
by crashing through hell
the grave
and death
and he gives you that life through faith
and through his word
now you say how is it given through his
word the resurrected life of christ
the revitalizing christ of life of
christ the quickening life of christ is
given through his word
john chapter 6
verse 51 jesus said i am the living
bread which came down from heaven if any
man eat of this bread he shall live
forever and the bread which i will give
is my flesh which i will give for the
life of the world the jews therefore
strove among themselves saying how can
this man give us his flesh to eat
jesus tells them verily verily i say
unto you except you eat the flesh of the
son of man and drink his blood he have
what no life
then he explains why he said that verse
the words that i speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life
there is
resurrected life in the word of god
why do you think the devil keeps you so
busy you have no time for this
that's why paul says in colossians
chapter 3 verse 1 if ye then be risen
with christ what does he mean risen with
christ you're still on the earth how are
you risen with christ by faith you enter
into his resurrection that's why paul
says that i may know him and the power
of his resurrection
if he then be risen with christ if you
by faith have entered the stream of that
resurrection power seek those things
which are above because that's what the
life of christ does it changes the mind
it alters the thinking it makes the
spiritual beings
and our greatest joy come from spiritual
things
not video games
and who wears what on a red carpet
and who divorce who
and then whatever they do
spiritual things because now we are
spiritual beings in the flesh
and that spiritual power i say is the
same power that allow christ to break
out of the tomb
and to ascend glorious
glorified and that power i repeat with
tedium is available to us my beloved
brothers and sisters as we go about our
business you and i
we ought to live with the consciousness
that while we may not have the
appearance of angels
we may not have
the glow on their faces
but we have their standard in our hearts
we must live
like we are in heaven
before we enter heaven
let me repeat that
when jesus comes
i told her he changes the body first
corinthians 15 51
behold i show you a mystery we shall not
all sleep but we shall all be changed in
a moment in the twinkling of an eye for
the trumpet shall sound and the dead
shall be raised and we shall all be
changed for this corruptable must put on
incorruption this model must put on
immortality that will happen in the
twinkling of an eye but that which has
been developed on the inside of the
character is untouched
because the transformation occurs before
jesus comes
christ isn't coming to save anyone
he's coming to collect the saved
are you following me
he is coming to get
those who have who are now being
transformed by his resurrected life
so paul says like as christ was raised
up from the grave by the glory of the
father even so we ought to walk in
newness of life what's the newness of
life the resurrected life of jesus
christ now he came up with the
resurrected life and the glorified body
we have the same weak body but in us can
exist that glorified life
even in this weak container we can have
the glory of god and that is what god
desires therein lies this tremendous
stupendous power of the gospel that in a
sinful person can be seen the life of
jesus christ
impossible you say and i say yes outside
of christ
in fallen flesh
[Music]
controlled by the spirit
can be seen clearly
the righteous life of jesus christ
that's why jesus says in john 14 verse
19 20
i will not leave you comfortless i will
come to you yet a little while and the
world's even seeth me no more because i
live ye shall live also in that day ye
shall know that i am in my father me and
me and i in you how is that possible
because his life is in us
there is no need my beloved brothers and
sisters to be trapped
weak
there is power available to us
that the combined military powers of
this earth do not understand and will
never have
and that's a power that cancels death
itself and that power is the resurrected
life of jesus christ
with that life we have the power to live
the character he developed before he
died
the question is
do we want that life
or are our taste buds so corrupted by
secularism and materialism that we
really have no desire for the life of
christ now we desire a decent life
christ can die to give you a decent life
you don't need christ's help to be a
decent person there are a lot of decent
atheists running around the place
there's a lot of people who serve satan
and they're decent you can't tell they
don't rob banks they don't shoot people
they don't rip they don't steal steal
hubcaps they don't do that but they have
nothing to do with god they are polite
they wear suits they go to work they are
respected but they have nothing to do
with god
i don't need god's help to be polite
i need god's help to know to open the
door for a lady
but i need god's help
to live above sin come on say something
i need god's help and the life above sin
is the life of christ
my question to you again politely as i
put away the holy book
is this your favorite book
are you fascinated by the possibility of
living the life of christ
sometimes when i stand here i wonder to
myself is 4 minutes to 8.
is it possible there's someone seated
there listening to me who feels really
no need for christ
i hope not but i wonder is someone
listening to me who feels in his or her
heart what's the big thing
i'm okay
if you feel that
come and talk to me in that room at the
side
because you are in mortal danger the
christian lives every day with a deep
sense of the need for jesus christ it's
like a man who's drowning he has to come
up for air and when he comes up he gulps
and you can hear him he sucks it in and
that's how we i need jesus
i need him
because i cannot save myself i cannot
walk the upright life i need the
resurrected life of jesus christ
to sustain me
how many of you will stay with me
tonight
or let me ask you this first how many of
you appreciate the message can i see
your hand
you mean that
not because of me but because it's the
god's word i try to stay as close as i
can to the word of god to stray is to be
dangerous get into waters you can't
manage
how many of you will say jesus
father
we're praying to the father the name of
jesus father
i want that resurrected powerful life of
jesus to work in me
if you will say that from your heart
without trying to impress anyone could
you stand up please
and i know i make you stand all the time
some of you have sent me prayer requests
you say pray for me i may be lost
i'm battling a sin no victory if those
requests you send i'd like to see you so
we can pray together
please
because when i pray with you i am
strengthened myself do you understand
that
is there someone here
who has a particular spiritual battle
and need special prayer two minister
eight a particular spirit i'm not
talking to all of you a particular
spiritual battle
and you need special prayer raise your
hand
i'm not talking to all of you not all of
you
come right here quickly
right
here and let's pray
god bless you come quickly
the rest of us heads bowed eyes
closed come by there brother and sister
i'll wait for you coming down the center
aisle my sister to the right god bless
you come
never heard bowed
pray with me as i pray for god's people
anyone else before i pray
our father in heaven
i come to you in a quiet moment
after trying my best to deliver the word
of god your word
your people have come and responded a
call that i have made i believe at your
direction
father we have one struggle or another
and we want power
the power is available through faith
and faith is holding on to jesus christ
or whatever he says and believing it
and allowing it to live in us
and so in the name of jesus father i ask
you now because you're not willing that
then he should perish
that you would lay your power upon each
person who moved requesting special
intervention for some spiritual struggle
of one kind or another
lord in the name of jesus help them to
understand the power comes by truly with
all their heart and soul and mind and
might and strength and understanding
embracing jesus as a real person who
loves them and desires to save them and
understands them
lord let us embrace him tonight by faith
in his word
that that power may work in our lives
change our minds that our greatest joy
may be spiritual things the things that
are above
remember the rest of us i pray they god
have mercy on us
you said in psalm 103 verse 13 he
knoweth our frame he remembers that
we're dust you know how weak we are
father we're not asking you to excuse it
understand and supply that power and
help us lift us up and hold us grab us
by the arm as you grab lot and pull us
out of sodom pull us out of gomorrah i
pray
and save us
we offer this prayer in jesus name and
for his sacred all god's people say amen